from High School Musical to portraying
one of the most infamous serial killers
of the 20th century playing Ted Bundy
took a toll on Zac Efron's body and mind
actors embodying psychopaths are nothing
new when it comes to cinema and
television the horror genre is filled
with a counterclastic examples but there
has always been a Sinister and
uncomfortable feeling when watching
real-life monsters come to life through
the wonders of performance in ephron's
case the mental anguish she endured in
embodying Ted Bundy became a struggle to
maintain his own mental health in such a
dark headspace one of the most bizarre
things about Ted Bundy was his ability
to fit into society in the 1970s and his
polished looks have often been cited as
one of the tools used to hide his
Sinister actions conscious of this
detail Zac Efron worked hard to change
aspects of his physical appearance to
capture the criminal's look in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly the
actor was asked about his process for
creating Bundy's look and replied we got
super specific with Ted's look I lost a
lot of weight for the role on all the
footage I could see Ted was always not
emaciated but was kind of a 70s cinewed
buff I worked to learn how to talk with
new teeth in I completely went on my
exercise bike every morning and would
watch kind of heavy stuff Efron
described the process of filming as
quote down and dirty and that much of
his time working on the film was on set
in Kentucky pepperon elaborated in this
movie we spent a lot of time in jail and
I officially know that's as much time as
I want to spend there it was only a
couple of hours but it's shocking Zac
Efron's commitment to imbuing mental
life into Ted Bundy was another obstacle
that presented challenges speaking to
metro.co.uk at the film's European
Premiere he was asked how he limited the
mental toll of the part he replied that
needing to remove himself from his
character so strictly was a new
experience for him and that it was
incredibly difficult he elaborated I
would like to say I separated myself
successfully but I couldn't when asked
if the movie and his performance
glamorized the psychopath he stated that
he tried not to romanticize such an evil
and violent person however Ephron
admitted that he was fascinated by the
opportunity to try and enter the mind to
Bundy as well as Bundy's former
girlfriend Elizabeth Kendall he
explained it's a different perspective
and not your run-of-the-mill serial
killer cliche body count gets higher
iron higher and oh the guy you always
know did it film it was what it was like
to be there on the day can you hear my
chains dangling no I can't
wearing any well watching Efron's acting
in the film it is both strange and a bit
disturbing to notice how a performer can
so convincingly recreate a notorious
serial killer whose actions still cause
so much pain for the families of his
numerous victims it was not a role
without pain and discomfort for The
Talented actor and he made a bold
decision to move forward with it
[Music]